your movie Lola has 27 executive
producers yes can you explain how that
works I did a crowdfunding cuz I didn't
have all the money to pay for it so I
did crowdfunding just gave everybody AP
credits and no equity just credit okay
and this was on which platform oh no I
just hit people up text email blast I
did a little bit in egogo but it wasn't
good so I just hit people up regular so
you did the Antoine Allen crowdfunding
campaign you know it okay yep okay and
so uh where do you post the people's
names just in the credits and on in and
um on the IMDb and in the movie so how
many people do you think you actually
text or emailed a lot of people how
many maybe 40 50 people okay and so
around half or so said yes closed mouth
don't get fed if you want something you
got to ask for it okay and um how may I
ask what was the amount that most people
put in 5,000 10,000
R and what did you have to show them
well they already knew my resume already
I've done tons of films already so it
was a yes or no and sometimes r one said
no they just didn't have the money right
okay and so by what how like how long
did it take to raise that money a month
one month okay and so how much money was
that so I put in 65 of my own money
and I raised like an extra 25,000 and
this is for Lola 1 yes okay mhm and then
Lola 2 now has five executive producers
yes are you one of them yes okay so then
you reached out to how many people
really one person and then a lot of
other people just friends that had me a
connection a location I just gave them a
credit okay so now you have aside from
Yourself four executive producers mhm
what changed how how come you had 27
before and then for Lola 2 now you have
four aside from yourself proof of
concept Lola one no one believed in but
it won't work so now I don't have to I
went to like one or two people to get
the money I need and that was it um one
of the the biggest invest I have that
PID for majority of the whole film was a
producer I met on clubhouse her name is
Monica Floyd from True Vision Media
Group um she's an angel she a guardian
angel cuz around Co happened I want to
do ler too but I didn't have the funding
like that so she invested majority of
film and I love her for that and
clubhouses it's a social media app um I
like it because not like Instagram and
Facebook you actually talk to people you
have a human human conversation with
them and we was in a room um was talking
about film and I said something about I
don't know so many people that's own
their content and she checked me she
said what are you talking about I'm a
producer in La I owe my contact and I
was like wow I didn't know so she
educated me most people they would have
an eagle like who you talking to but no
I was here to learn and she educated me
said an you don't know about me but I do
this and this and when I found out who
she was I was like Wow and she believed
in me she wrote the check and produced
the whole film with me so from the time
that you met her on clubhouse what was
the time span then that you started
filming Lola too so it was a mirica
I met her on clubhouse in March I went
to LA to meet her face to face in like
April May and July we start filming oh
wow she was I said she a guardian angel
because with me my words match my action
in this industry most people talk with
her she was like what you want to do let
do it and now we Unstoppable cuz you
don't meet people like that in the
regular but that happened because I was
ready prepared you know the old saying
stay ready you have to get ready
so I had all my ducks in a row I did
projects before and we just hit it off
and um it was a blessing what was it
about Lola too that made her want to
invest it was really me that's not I
tell people too sometimes people want to
invest in your project they want to
invest in you so I tell people L of
times be a good person be about your
business be kind but
really I right now if it was another
movie she would just be invested in me
cuz she believe in my hustle and she see
that I'm out here doing what I got to do
and she's giving back so um Monica will
be watching it so I appreciate you okay
so shout out to Monica shout out to
Monica Floy okay and Lola 2 is finished
or couple more scenes we in post almost
done rap and it we releaseing next year
wow yeah do you have like an email list
where you keep all the Lola one
people so sometimes when they when not
sometimes when they go by my merch I got
the email address I'm really Act on
social media so I talk to people get the
information I try to I try to stay
active I learn that from Tyler Perry
when Tyler Perry first came out he still
does it but not so much he have a email
list he us to email send an email back
thank you everybody have a human human
connection um I learn that from TY per
to really connect with your fans make
one fan at a time CU those are people
that gonna keep the lights on let's go
back to Monica for a moment so what was
the pitch you said you met her on
clubhouse which is a social media app
mhm so once I met her on social media
once she checked me cuz I didn't know I
didn't know who she was um we talk on
the phone went back and forth I show her
Lola one but really wasn't even a movie
she really believes in me and sometimes
you help people like I help a lot of
people help a lot of actors fil I help a
lot of people because I believe in
giving helping people but this was just
karma coming back to me everybody I help
everybody looked at it could be any
movie I think she still would invest
Because She Believes In Me and sometimes
not about your project it's about the
indidual sometimes I help people or I
invest in people had nothing to do with
their project it's because of them so
there was no pitch it was a pitch people
don't realize when you open your mouth
you're pitching it don't have to be a
form to be a PDF you're pitching when
you walk in the room it's your brand
soon you open your mouth so people don't
realize that's a pitch so be ready so
when someone say hey I'm interested in
you know what you're talking about be a
man in your word be about your business
so don't do don't people don't realize
that you're pitch is yourself you're
pitching yourself when you walk in the
room you he a brand so that was a pitch
is Lola a brand or is Antoine Allen a
brand it's all together that's my
baby which brand do you think is
stronger
Lola why because me I'm an individual
but Lola is a story that takes someone
emotional roller coaster and deals with
pain tra Underdog Triumph and Lola I'm
the first person ever to make a female
boxing franchise never been done before
it's my female versin of Rocky like with
Million Dollar Baby nope do you I know
it wasn't a franchise what what
similarities are in that character and
then how is she totally different
totally different one she
African-American two a Million Dollar
Baby was a old woman getting into boxing
so it's like night and day um but with
Lola Lola is a a woman that had nothing
do with boxing and she used training and
self-defense cuz she didn't want to be a
victim no more and she in boxing so most
boxing films or all boxing films the
family is a boxer they want to be a
boxer she never wanted to be a boxer she
just wanted to do self-defense and she
fell into boxing so it's almost like
Boys Don't Cry and million dooll baby
and in some similarities no no no it's
Lola one one of one Lola's her own
person yep does Lola feel real to you
yes it's a Underdog Story it's you know
she turned her pain into to purpose
she took her pain instead of dwelling in
it she took a power back she was a her
on her story and same thing with me I
came from home beginning now I'm a hero
in my story um but yes it's amazing it's
amazing that this was a short film I did
eight years ago split decision was Lola
it was a at the time I have the money
for it so I did Split Decision I did a
short film so I tell people to do baby
steps sometimes we can't get the big
budget so do babies to do little Pebbles
and it was a short film and eight nine
years later we had a franchise what
prompted you to do the short film I
wanted to do a film after I got the the
music business I wanted to do something
that stand out and every time I go to
the film festivals it's the same exact
stories dramas so let me what did I
could do to stand out and I did a female
boxing film and that was expired because
of Rocky like I love the rocky franchise
and Sylvester's own story is just
amazing if you if you know it and so
would you go to rings and see some of
these women boxers or or or you know
mixed martial art Fighters when I was
young I used to box I used to box in
gleon Gym in Brooklyn and I love boxing
I see female box and I was like why
never been African-American boxing film
a franchise so with me a lot of times we
look at things we complain I'll say you
know what send me complain let me be the
solution that's what happened did you
used to see a woman that reminded you of
Lola no oh no never I just this was I
use my imagination so you're working on
Lola 2 now almost finished yes what
happens after Lola 2 we put it out next
year and next summer hopefully we get
ready for L 3 I'm GNA do a Trilogy do
you think you'll stop at that um no I'm
probably to Lo to TV
series why do you think people want to
see her journey why does why is one
movie not enough two movies and maybe
three and Beyond um it's me I I don't
think the story is complete and then I
want to do my own female Rocky franchise
and um I just love the franchise let me
do something different because as
filmmakers we don't think about
franchise we think about one and done
I'm big on franchise like I love
franchise so um this would be one of my
first franchise but I have some more and
it works how do you pitch
Lola what you mean when when you go to
pitch it or when you're sort of in your
mind if you do go and Pitch this TV
series what what is the pitch well
actually Lola one two is a pitch
because it's proof of concept I did it
already so really when anything um if
you pitch in a project it's already done
already you already have the proof of I
PE so it's an easy pitch to be like hey
I did one and two um it's doing really
well it's do a series so you know well
let's say there was a party and let's
say this is so you and I are there at
the party and I'm like oh really you're
a filmmaker oh and you have this tell me
what is tell me about Lola Lola is a
female boxing film it's Underdog Story
it's my female version of Rocky
franchise and is the first ever African
American female boxing franchise in the
history of
Cinema and and why is Lola for a broad
audience because it's an unul Story the
average person means unor story when you
see the rich people as 1% the average
person I know more poor people than rich
people and that's why they connect to it
and women run the
world yeah good answer
yeah but do you think even rich people
so the quote unquote 1% maybe can
identify with being an underdog in a
sense that maybe they've been crushed in
a business deal or they can family
squabbles or whatever yeah they can they
can but I know the majority of people
are underdogs and they're looking for
their fight so um we could go to the
movies and see the big hero movies
that's great but I'm big on watching
movies that have a human connection I
didn't go to film suit I didn't have no
Mentor this is a straight G gift like I
said before someone told me i' be doing
this I laugh any face this I don't have
like I don't like things I'm doing I
don't just it's God gift I don't have no
training I don't have no Mentor I didn't
go to no big film so I have nobody it's
just my god- talent do you think people
are taking you more seriously because
you've created a franchise people taking
me more serious because I'm
consistent when you consistent and
you're not going away like I've been
doing
this a long time like a long time most
of my life I've been entertaining
business so yeah take my Ser I'm not
going no still around I'm not stopping
some people have seasons my season
hasn't end yet so it's just I'm being
more consistent when you consistent and
they keep seeing you year after year
it's like wow this guy is not playing
around how have the conversations
changed dramatically because most
independent filmmakers are not making
money like I
done 20 over 20 short
films three to four features like I'm
consistent and I execute cuz at the end
of day you have all the money in the
world or connections world it's all
about execution so now you know L to is
it's uh it's amazing I can't wait
everybody see it how can you tell though
that people are taking you more
seriously what do they ask or what do
they say that's different than before
they want to give me
money okay I think that that's a good
indicator yeah they want to give me
money and they want to help me they see
the vision now they see what I'm doing
you know you put in your work you know
you put put in your hundred something
hours and you will get rewarded so I'm
seeing that now I'm working with name
actors Lola to is my first film i l one
too I work with Taj V Simpson amazing
actress um she's on to per hit shoulder
oval and I'm working with name actors
now so that's another indicated like wow
people want to work with you you know
it's a
journey